كانت [الموسيقى]
للعديد
من التسوق من المنزل هو الخيار الوحيد
لعدة أشهر
حيث أجبر الوباء المتاجر على إغلاق
أبوابها
، حيث كان على صناعة الأزياء
أن تتطور وتتكيف.
أدت عمليات الإغلاق إلى خسائر فادحة في شركة Ted
baker ،
لذا قامت باستثمارات كبيرة في
عملياتها عبر الإنترنت ،
فقد تعاونت مع شركة تكنولوجيا
رائدة تتيح للعملاء التحدث من خلال
الملابس والمنتجات عبر وظيفة الدردشة في الوقت الفعلي ،
مما يعني أنه يمكن للعلامات التجارية الفاخرة
إدخالها  - تجربة المتجر مباشرة إلى منزلك ، تتمثل
إحدى الابتكارات الأخرى التي يقدمها البطل في
وضع
وجه للتسوق عبر الإنترنت ، يمكنك إجراء محادثة بالفيديو
مع أحد العاملين في المتجر لمساعدتك في
اتخاذ قرار
نيابة عني اليوم ، فهل سأقول نعم للفستان
مرحبًا مرحبا ليا  أستطيع أن أرى أنك لست في
المتجر فقط ولكنك في
الواقع ترتدي الفستان الذي لدي بعض الأسئلة
حول
أنا بالفعل فستان الكيك نعم كان هذا
هو الذي أردت فقط أن
أعرفه  يمكن أن يكتشف ti ذلك
بالطبع بالطبع ، لذا
فإن الفستان في الواقع هو عبارة عن ثورة جديدة
في فستان القميص
منذ إطلاقه ، تحدث تيد بيكر إلى
أكثر من 15000
عميل من خلال منصة التسوق الافتراضية هذه ،
وكان لدينا القدرة
على الاستفادة من البطل  في نموذج العمل من المنزل
لفرق متجرنا ،
مما مكّن عددًا محددًا من فرق المتجر من
أن يكونوا
من راحة منازلهم
قادرين على تقديم خدمة رائعة
لراحة منزل العميل وكذلك
هل كان لديك أي  التحفظات عندما
سمعت عن البطل لأول مرة
وفكرت في تبنيه ،
لا أعني أننا أردنا احتضان
أي شيء من شأنه
تعزيز تجربة العميل
وإضافة القيمة المضافة الحقيقية للعملاء التي تأسست في المملكة المتحدة ،
بدأ الأبطال بالهدف النهائي
من إضفاء الطابع الإنساني على التجارة الإلكترونية ، كنت في الواقع
قيد الانتظار في متجر الكتب المحلي الخاص بي
وكنت أحاول معرفة ما إذا كان لديهم
كتاب متاح وكنت في الانتظار
لأفكر في أن هذا ليس
بالذات  تجربة آرلي الودية في
القرن الحادي والعشرين مع وجود بصمة
في 30 سوقًا حول العالم
، استحوذت Hiro على عالم الموضة والجمال من خلال الشراكة مع العلامات التجارية الأوروبية الكبرى مثل كلوي وسيفورا ،
يقول مؤسسها إن التواصل البشري المباشر
هو سر
زيادة
المبيعات وهو ما كان مجنونًا بالنسبة لي.  في
مجال البيع بالتجزئة كشخص تقني
هو أن 99 شخصًا قاموا بضرب علامة تجارية أو
موقع ويب بائع تجزئة
ولم يشتروا شيئًا ما ، فقط واحد بالمائة
سيستمرون في التحويل ، لذلك قلنا جيدًا
لماذا لا يشترونه كما كنت في
نقطتي السابقة حول أنهم يريدون ذلك  أن يكونوا
قادرين على
رؤية المنتج الذي يريدون أن يكونوا قادرين على سؤال
أحد الخبراء عنه ، فهذه الأسباب هي التي
تمنعهم من الشراء
وتغير مستقبل بطل البيع بالتجزئة.
فقط
الاستمرار في رؤية زيادة في النمو في
أعمالنا لأنني أعتقد أن معظم
تجار التجزئة
يرون الآن أنهم بحاجة إلى أن يكونوا أكثر مرونة
وأن يستثمروا في التكنولوجيا التي
يعرفون أنها موجودة لتبقى
تضيف الشركة الآن قصص بطل ميزة جديدة
مثل الكثير من موظفي التجزئة في instagram ، حيث
سيتمكنون من تحميل مقاطع فيديو
باختيار الزي
الذي يختارونه وهذا ما يتعرف عليه العملاء
ويريدون أن يروا
أنك تعرف شخصًا عاديًا يتحدث عن
منتج ما لأنهم أشخاص عاديون
التسوق أيضًا
لسد الفجوة بين
الاقتراب والشخصية في وضع عدم الاتصال وعبر الإنترنت عاد إلى
الأناقة
آنا ستيوارت cnn london